- [Katie] These are the
horses that don't fit in
in any other place.
All of these abandoned animals
were getting sent to slaughter.
They would have been killed.
I think what they're
doing here is incredible.
I'm born and raised in New York City.
I still live here and base here
even though most of my work
is pretty far away and abroad.
You get into the city life,
and it's really important
to get away from all of that
and to go somewhere
that's closer to nature,
but also have the
opportunity to slow down.
I'm on assignment for National Geographic.
I'm going up to Rosemary Farm Sanctuary,
which is a horse rescue
in upstate New York.
It's this really interesting place
where horses are living a life
that you're not accustomed to seeing.
They're letting animals
live in a really different
and unique way, and the
animals are relating to people
in a really unique way.
I hope that I can capture
that with the images
and people can read this story,
and maybe it's just a
break from the normal news
that they're looking at.
Every story that you tell
doesn't have to be so dark
and difficult and gritty.
- Nemo is an unusual donkey.
This is not normal donkey behavior.
When he was at the hospital
and we had his leg amputated
and they started teaching him
how to wear his prosthetic,
they spent a lot of time with him.
And one person would sit
at his head and cuddle
and the other person would put the leg on.
And so he developed this routine.
- [Katie] Something I
really wanted to capture was
putting on Nemo's prosthetic leg,
and I know it's just a really big part
of their daily routine there
for the people, but then also for Nemo.
- [Man] Come on, Nemo, you wanna come out?
- [Katie] He was injured
when he was really little,
and it's not normal for
equine animals to live
if they lose a leg.
- Come on, Nemo.
- [Katie] It's pretty cool
to watch the journey of this
really resilient and
inspiring little creature.
He's ready, let's go Nemo.
Hey, beauty.
I never know where I'm
gonna find inspiration.
It oftentimes comes from stories
and sometimes it comes from chance.
There's this energy here,
so that's something I
really wanted to take.
I really wanted to sort of capture a moment
where you could feel the energy
of all the horses as one,
the feeling of them as a herd
and the strength of that.
But it's also dangerous. These
are really powerful creatures
and there's also, a lot of them,
they were put up to slaughter
because they won't obey
and they won't act like what
people consider a normal horse
to act like, and that's okay,
they get to be free there,
but then I'm on their turf.
With everything that's
going on in the world,
especially what's happening
to the environment,
it's almost like
photographing a way of life
where there's this really
deep connection with nature
and this interconnectedness
between people and animals,
it's almost like you're capturing history.
This is just as important
as any huge news story.
It's just a little harder to grasp.
When I've shot something
special, I know immediately.
Everything comes together
and it just says something
much more than what you're
seeing in front of you.
(intense electronic music)